[Musique]
eh bien bon soir diagonale l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs bonsoir
et loi bonsoir stéphane avec un
programme très chargé de quantité
entraînés à leur compte et très vite
pour un homme très chargé laurent
frayssinet vainqueur au sénat tournoi
anniversaire de victor cornouaille avec
la victoire impressionnante de vladimir
kramnik contre kasparov
il y a également le mémorial capable
entier avec la présence de nos deux
français arnaud hauchard et hibernate a
fait évidemment au cours de cette
édition stéphane une petite route chez
people avec jean-luc chabanon en direct
de came également annonce de tourner en
vrac mais surtout les parties
commentaires surtout les parties
commentées avec une super partie grammy
kasparov superbe partie on y viendra
tout à l'heure il y aura également aussi
deux petites combinaisons si nous avons
le temps puisque le programme est assez
chargé petite combinaison de tony miles
qui bat igor nataf à cuba est également
combinaison de kasparov qui fait une
très belle attaque de match contre
viktor qu'au final on va rappeler
mémoire est incapable en cas capable en
cas c'est le nom d'un ancien champion du
monde d'échecs capablanca le cube un nom
qui était ambassadeur de cuba en même
temps et qui donc est mort
ça fait quelques années déjà maintenant
et qui était championne du monde dans
les années 20 30 et qui donc voit un
mémorial à son nom organisée à cuba
depuis maintenant plus de 20 ans c'est
vrai que c'était quand même le joueur
cubain le plus fort de tous les temps
son niveau n'a jamais été atteint depuis
par un joueur cubain en tout cas c'est
clair que capable en cas était enfin est
encore là bas une star de toute façon on
va essayer encore une star et là celui
qui l'a remplacé dans le coeur des
cubains c'est arencibia on peut dire qui
et qui a été championne du monde junior
d'ailleurs il m'a dit c'est le seul qui
a été championne du monde junior depuis
capablanca la nouvelle star cubaine donc
walter arencibia qui est un héros de
1550 donc on voit qu'on est pas loin du
niveau d'un champion du monde
oui tout à fait alors on va peut-être
démarré avec la première partie commenté
oui oui on peut quand même rappeler
quand même on peut parler un peu de
laurent frayssinet au sénat puis soyez
donc déjà rappelé qu on peut le
retrouver dans diagonale événements oui
revivre tous les matches et également
détaillé un petit peu son parcours parce
que c'est quand même la mascotte de
diagonale c'est quand même un événement
il faut donc en parler stéphane savoie
on peut pas on peut pas ignorer la
victoire
week-end dernier de laurent frayssinet
au sénat la surprise générale c'est le
plus petit et l'eau et il va le jouer le
lotier qui était déjà une première
surprise et ensuite il confirme en
vacances parce qu'ils fissent a
finalement sans prendre trop de risques
oui l'euro freyssinet qui a pris boris
spassky à son propre piège puisqu'on
sait que ce pas ce qui est un joueur
très solide donc très difficile à battre
il a pris son temps laurent frayssinet
il n'a pas essayé de forcer il a fait
deux nuls dans les parties semi-rapides
des nuls solide
ensuite des nuls en blitz ont pensé que
l'expérience de ce pas ce qui allait
finalement payé contre leurs offres et
siné qui allait peut-être finir par
s'endormir et en fait non c'est tout le
contraire dans cette deuxième partie de
la deuxième série blitz donc c'était
déjà la sixième partie entre les deux
joueurs est bien laurent frayssinet
s'impose très très brillamment
c'est une des plus belles victoires de
laurent frayssinet on peut l'on peut le
dire c'est une des plus belles
performances de sa carrière c'est clair
avec évidemment les titres chez les
jeunes puisque on sait qu'il a été vice
champion du monde des moins de 18 ans
qui déjà bien vice champions du monde
benjamin toujours 2e mais cette fois ci
c'est enfin premier enfin premier il
confirmé il progresse à pas de géants il
va passer les 2006 lots probablement
prochaine classement il a déjà plus de
2600 20 au classement fictif un
classement qui n'est pas publié mais qui
va l'être donc cédé extrêmement bien il
va rejoindre etienne bacrot on peut en
profiter stéphane pour appeler le site
qui a été partenaire du sénat s'est donc
sport hasek qui passe en ce moment
nombreuses interviews des joueurs il ya
des interviews de christian bauer et de
laurent frayssinet il ya également
jean-luc chavanon qui a été interpellé
et on peut citer un petit passage de
l'interview de laurent frayssinet qui
dit voilà le match qui me faisait peur
c'était contre joël lautier parce qu'il
est très fort et mais déjà battu 2 à 0
mais donc une fois que les battues je me
suis senti beaucoup plus détendue espace
qui je savais qu'il était solide donc je
me suis simplement dit ça prendra plus
longtemps
voilà ça prendra plus longtemps donc
assez serein quand même en france il n'a
pas craqué et a fait une excellente
performance donc on vous invite à revoir
et bien toutes ces vidéos tous les
matches en direct diffusé en vidéo sur
des gones à l'événement senna 2001
évidemment pas confondre avec senna 2000
puisqu'on aussi l'édition du sénat 2000
qui est en vidéo à la demande ou qui est
intéressante aussi puisque c'est shirov
qui avait gagné le tournoi en battant ce
même boris spassky en finale donc boris
spassky toujours deuxième au sénat oui
bon espace qui est un peu la scoumoune
au sénat on peut donc enchaîner avec le
mémorial capable en cas
appelez donc que ça se passe à cuba que
c'est un temps on va le long puisqu'il
ya donc treize joueurs 14 secondes pour
notre elles ont un trait sur deux rondes
mais un jour de repos moyenne lots de
1552 c'est donc un très fort tournoi et
c'est probablement ce les fans le seul
tournoi important qui a lieu à cuba
oui c'est le seul tournoi de catégorie
internationale qui a lu à cuba
effectivement mais tous les ans il ya
des français d'ailleurs tous les ans qui
vend quasiment je croyais tienne bacrot
il est à l'ina une année et fait un bon
résultat je crois sans doute ouais il
était le maquereau est très fort
et puis cette année on a deux français
on à igorre nataf et un an au chat voilà
un petit peu là bas j'aurais tendance à
dire en touriste mais c'est pas tout à
fait vrai puisque les joueurs d'échecs
sont quand même avant tout
professionnelle sont donc obligés de
faire des résultats
mais en croisant arnaud hauchard et igor
nataf avant le tournoi et bien on a
l'impression qu'ils voulaient quand même
bien profiter de cuba est évidemment
pour une fois des joueurs d'échecs
s'intéresse aux paysages on ne peut que
les féliciter
alors pour en revenir si on va en faire
venir un autre parti commentés dû jour
c'est au mémorial
koch noël alors l'anniversaire de corse
ne règle pas ce que florian est toujours
vivant puisqu'il a joué son propre sens
propre tournoi c'est l'anniversaire de
contenant et 70 ans est toujours dans
les 30 meilleurs joueurs mondiaux
oui alors il a toujours plus de 2650 au
classement vélo c'est remarquable parmi
les joueurs à 70 ans et plus le joueur
qui est juste après lui n'a que deux
mille quatre cent cinquante je crois
qu'il s'agit de miguel nachoff donc le
joueur argentin argentin exactement
donc bon victor cornouaille qui
pulvérise entre guillemets le
championnat du monde super vétérans à
plus de 70 ans
c'est une compétition fictifs qui
n'existe pas mais si elle avait lieu est
bien évidemment ça serait victor kornoi
l'énorme favori alors la composition du
tournoi on va l'a rappelé il ya trois
groupes
enfin dans le tournoi ya un seul groupe
de joueurs mais il y avait deux trois
catégories de joueurs invités donc il y
avait les tops way kasparov cram knicks
fille de l'air bon il y avait également
l'or aussi short epic est donc ça
c'était il y avait des fours joueurs il
y avait des suisses puisque le temps est
venu ensuite
ouais il y avait donc florian dziennik
le nouveau joueur jeune suisse yannick
pelletier qui est champion de suisse il
y avait également eu dycker mais ça lui
il est dans la troisième catégorie la
catégorie qu'on peut qualifier de papy
ouais les papilles donc il y avait 4 il
y avait eu 10 coeurs se fasse qui
écorche cornouaille exactement il y en
avait encore un je ne sais plus qui
s'était donc il y avait voilà des tops
des suisses et des papilles pour les 70
ans de cortelin qui est suisse qui est
top et qui est un peu âgées et bien donc
tout le monde était représentée superbe
tournoi et victor corse ne s'en est pas
mal sorti lyn a été éliminée
malheureusement que par kasparov
mais la grande surprise de ce tournoi
stéphane c'est le duel final qu'est-ce
que rohff contre communique enfin c'est
un peu le duel attendu est par contre ce
qui cependant attendait c'était
est-ce que cramique allait confirmer son
match contre kasparov et bien
effectivement il confirmé réussi à
battre battre encore une fois kasparov
il est en train de devenir sa véritable
bête noire complètement complètement à
l'image donc de la partie du jour que
vous avez ici à l'écran vladimir kramnik
à les blancs contre garry kasparov
stéphane une très grosse partie
évidemment garry kasparov quand ils
jouent contre chronique avec les noirs
repense forcément au match de londres
mais oui forcément forcément et
chroniques ne change pas ça qu'à sa
technique il continue toujours d'ouvrir
avec le coup un des quatre des quatre
villes a dit mercredi contre garry
kasparov cavadee m6
alors là a noté stéphane comme une
grosse particularité c'est que c'est un
semi rapide oui
donc ça c'est ça change tout ça change
tout puisque les coûts sont plus
intuitif et moins de calculs à tort ses
4 e 6 l'admirent chronique au
championnat du monde avait joué
systématiquement stéphane ou quasiment
le cook et c3 qui permettait la ligne
the beach et l'a donc la ligne 8 chefs
des quatre qui coule cavaliers en
prenant contrôle des cases blanches mais
là il ne le permet pas il joue cavalier
f3 donc un coût différent puisque ça ne
permet pas fou mais quatre qui coule
cavaliers qui a des avantages notamment
celui d'éviter les neuf victimes étaient
aussi des inconvénients c'est que ça
permet par exemple à garry kasparov de
jouer le coup 17 des cinq en évitant le
gambit dame variantes des changes
donc en fait c'est de toute façon dans
les ouvertures un tout se vaut c'est une
citation de joël lautier dans les
ouvertures quand on cherche bien toutes
les ventes se valent et sont égales ici
qui avait des trous qui a laissé 3 c'est
une affaire de goût évidemment les deux
joueurs connaissent les subtilités ici
kasparov joue des cinq transposant dans
un candidat mais en évitant certaines
variantes
voilà tout à fait alors la banque rami
continue avec le coup logique avait
laissé trois développement de tests ou
certaines options dans la pièce et la
kasparov opte pour une variante je crois
viennoise c'est ça c'est la valse
viennoise du gambit dame pions france et
4 on prend un c'est 4 alors à noter
évidemment que le coût principal dans
cette position
c'est le coup fourré fuite en deux sets
et là on aura une position hyper connu
les matches marathon
garry kasparov contre anatoli karpov
moscou 85 ou cette position a eu lieu
dans plus de trois parties sur quatre
puisque les joueurs jouent ça avec les
blancs et avec les noirs donc
l'évaluation est à peu près égale mais
en tout cas ici garry kasparov a décidé
de jouer dépensé 4 donc en semi rapides
on le rappelle stéphane ya un effet
psychologique important kasparov ne joue
pas souvent ce coup il a sans doute
voulu surprendre
il a su bien voulu surprendre cramique
cramique se laisse pas démonter il joue
un coup le plus solide on veut dire le
plus le moins risqué oui parce que
sûrement que la continuation ici la plus
forte c'est de jouer eux deux quatre
probablement c'est la continuation la
plus forte c'est en tout cas celle qui
est recommandée par la théorie la
théorie on va rappeler ce que celle et
stéphane c'est l'ensemble des parties
jouées l'ensemble des parties jouées
avait commenté ils ont analysé par les
meilleurs joueurs
exactement c'est donc tout ce qui est
déjà connu dans ce qui est déjà connu
donc on considère que dans cette
pression après la présence et 4 il faut
avancer l'option eu deux ans le 4 avec
des positions très très complexe ensuite
le fou et fuite vient sur la case b4 il
ya du contre jeu dans tous les sens ça
chauffe
vladimir kramnik en semi rapides n'étant
pas sûr de lui en étant patient de se
rappeler des variantes qui sont
extrêmement tendu et compliqué préfère
jouer le coup 5 e 3 ça a un avantage
c'est que ça défend le centre et sa
récupération c4 obligatoirement de
manière forcée puisque les noirs ne
peuvent pas le défendre donc chronique
ici prend une décision on va dire
pratique à 6 ça c'est normal vous allez
comprendre l'idée de ce coup tout de
suite après puisqu'ici on menace de
jouer des cinq sets et femmes aux
menaces de protéger le pion fou prend
ses quatre ont fait b5 quand même donc
lengagne un temps sur le fou puisque on
attaque food et 3 et maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire dans cette position il ya une
structure de pions qui est à l'avantagé
des blancs sur le long terme il faut
donc réagir
il faut réagir et en général il faut pas
laisser les blancs trop solide au centre
c'est une réaction classique que va
faire kasparov une réaction qu'on voit
même y compris d'un gandhi dame avec une
variante connu des retards h je crois
oui tout à fait qui permet de contre
attaquer au centre et qui est classique
dans beaucoup de positions c'est à dire
qu'on essaie de ne pas se laisser
étouffer dans cette position peut très
bien imaginer que les blancs arrive à
mettre un plan b 4 il arriverait à
pousser b2b cats est possible ensuite
avec un duo de pions en d4 et en c4 ils
contrôleraient gravement la casse et 5
qui
donc un pion c'est cet arriéré pour les
noirs ça c'est l'idée stratégique des
blancs dans cette position est
évidemment les noirs comme ils sont ils
ont le temps ils sont en avance il joue
c'est cette c5
voilà avec l'invite l'invite évidente
c'est que si les blancs prennent ces
cinq ans gagne un temps de développer un
certain le fou faut prendre l'air fou
prend 6,5
donc là il ya plus qu'à compter les
pièces sorties après le foot france et 5
3 pièces pour les blancs 2 pour les
noirs c'est donc à peu près équilibré au
niveau de la structure d'options
stéphane ça deviendrait complètement
symétrique
oui effectivement puisqu'il y aurait
d'autres belles dames et quatre piolets
le roi des deux côtés dans cette
position delà des murs krainik ne tolère
pas les pions a6b 5 le coup qu'on aurait
tendance à conseiller
c'est de jouer petit rock quand même
stéphane oui on a envie de croquer
puisque ça a l'air d'être le moment mais
cramique ne le fait pas alors on va
peut-être expliquer pourquoi alors que
là nous avons du verre mais c'était
momentanée évidemment puisque ça a été
récupérée petit rock c'est le coût
attendu mais kramnik ne joue pas et
qu'elle est qu'elle est en fait
l'explication pourquoi kamnik décide de
ne pas tout de suite rauque et ça on
peut se poser des questions quand même
mais peut-être il a envie d'engager
aussi dit et tout de suite il veut pas
que les baignoires se concentre il veut
pas permettre au noir je me fous des 7
par exemple
oui je pense qu'en fait je pense que
c'est exactement ça c'est que dans cette
position les noirs sur le long terme
vont seeds arrive à stabiliser leur
position est bien la structure va
égaliser
c'est la structure de les pions c et d
vont s'échanger tout simplement
on aura donc une structure de pions égal
il faut absolument trouver des choses
maintenant avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
dans quelques coups kasparov aura sorti
toutes ces pièces dont chronique ne
tolère pas ça il joue tout de suite une
réaction à 2 à 4 il n'est pas pressé de
roque et il est d'abord pressé de
provoquer des changements pendant que
les noirs n'ont pas encore sorti toutes
leurs pièces
donc la question en fait le problème
philosophique on va dire ok ou ne pas re
ok on a toujours envie de re ok mais il
faut toujours se demander si tout le
monde sort ses pièces de façon normale
qu'est ce qui va résulter bien ici on
voit tout de suite que la pression sera
égale donc il ne faut par ok quand on a
les blancs et qu'on joue pour le mien à
2 à 4 donc ça posait la question que bon
piont b5 été attaqué par le pion à 4 le
cav a laissé 3 et le foot est roi
donc c'était intenable pour les noirs il
fallait forcément soit prendre 1 4 qui
aurait t'il sûrement une mauvaise
décision
puisque ça ouvrait la colonne de la tour
soit poussé b4y kasparov honte pour la
deuxième option n'a pas vraiment souri
garry kasparov dans cette position il
joue donc b5 des quatre attaques lequel
ces trois ce qui allait doit déménager
et vient naturellement sur la case aux
quatre pour rire de quatre centres ça a
l'air d'être mieux que de venir sur la
case de 2 où il aurait un peu embêté les
propres pièces des blancs oui parce que
les blancs doivent faire attention
stéphane il faut pas oublier ça non plus
c'est que la structure de pions
maintenant à changer
elle a été bouleversée par le cou à 4 b
4 enfin c'est les deux derniers coups et
ici les noirs commencent à prendre de
l'espace ils gagnent du terrain mais
gagnait un peu de terrain
donc il faut surtout pas repartir en
arrière il faut plutôt aller de l'avant
pendant que justement on compte les
pièces sorties les bleus en ont sorti
trois années noires une seule il faut
donc aller de l'avant jouer cavalier ou
4 ne pas avoir peur de la menace directe
ce qui a eu lieu quatre fonctions c5
sans surprise garry kasparov n'a pas
envie de jouer qu'avec franck cavallier
puisqu'après fou prend il serait obligé
de perdre encore du temps pour protéger
sa tour habite pour la bouche et donc
elle joue qui avait 17 sur une pièce
défendre qu'à 26 pour f1 coup parfait et
défend les pions 600 et des champions
c'est ça la chronique choisi de prendre
un f6 il prend pas si c'est les noirs
qui pourront prendre le cap peut-être
pas forcément mais dans cette position
les noirs vont simplement je le fous
mais c'est de toute façon vous bessette
et on pourra pas de tenir le cavalier
1,4 ça va arriver finalement au même
donc cavani prend et six cavaliers prend
et maintenant le coût petit rock non
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il a décalé le
rock vladimir kramnik pour provoquer
garry kasparov à prendre de l'espace
donc c'est curieux donc il a fait venir
un peu oui il le fait avancé
l'explication est simple je pense
stéphane il a voulu casser ce duo pion à
6b 5
et puis on était situé comme ça il a
provoqué une flambée 5 et avancer sur la
case b4 et maintenant qu'est ce qu'il va
faire là dès mercredi kevin va mettre la
pression avec s'en fout des trois vers
le pion à 6 et 6 options bougeait bien
il y aura la casse b5 qui fera chaque au
roi parce que n'oublions pas que dans
cette position est bien les noirs n'ont
pas encore ok les noirs sont en retard
de développement donc yves évidemment
ici vladimir kramnik la jouer l'activité
il va mettre la pression sur lyon à six
et le troisième plan et bien il va nous
montrer très très vite
après tout bessette ici vladimir kramnik
c'est le moment du plan il faut trouver
comment faire pour faire
thiviers la petite avance de
développement dès demain well as pas
évident il va jouer un coup qui parle
cas pas l'art tout à fait évident lundi
mercredi qu' puisqu'il choisit
maintenant de prendre le pion à ses 5
qui al'air d'accélérer le développement
des noirs exactement alors alors qu'en
fait c'est le contraire alors c'est ça
qu'il faut expliquer c'est une position
complexe
évidemment les blancs donc on réussit à
provoquer quelques affaiblissement avec
leurs coûts à 4 et maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire un bien il faut jouer
ce coup thématique de 3 e 4 stéphane 3,4
mais pour l'instant on ne peut pas parce
que le cas ce qu'a très bien contrôlé
par les noirs la case aux 4 et bien
contrôlée et en plus l'option des quatre
se retrouveraient emprise donc ça ça
fait deux problèmes dans un premier
temps donc il joue des français 5 alors
on va envisager que vladimir kramnik
dans cette pression de dameuses
directement là il y aurait si on prend
des quatre qu'elle va les prendre et 4
et maintenant tout simplement un coup
comme fou au set et là on voit que les
blancs et ils ont du mal à jouer aux
cartes parce que le cahier des quatre
reprises tout simplement et donc rami
qui a voulu éviter ça donc dans cette
position il a joué puis en france et 5
d'abord foot français 5 et dames de
maintenant qui menacent donc le coup et
trois ou quatre coups qui va donc
enfermé le fou bessette restreindre le
cac edf 6 et ensuite permettre aux
blancs de mettre le fond g5 avec le
développement d'une forte initiative
dans cette position donc la cascade ou
dan des cinq contrôleurs une fois de
plus la case de 4 et donc empêchant le
cou aux 3/4 puisque maintenant l'option
sera en prise donc d'amener 5
en plus on voit une batterie on se
demande pourquoi on ne joue pas le coup
cavaliers ou quatre qui permettait aussi
de bloquer le pion oui cavaliers au cap
dans cette position c'était tout à fait
envisageable et pourquoi il ne l'a pas
joué et bien sans doute à cause de ces
deux peut-être mais c'est avec le
cavalier le fou ces cinq canadiens 4
c'est ce coup là peut-être il y avait
dams et 2,7 à vérifier c'est clair qui a
eu lieu aux quatre c'est vrai que ça a
l'air d'être le moyen le plus radical en
tout cas de bloquer le pion dam des cinq
tours d un peu dès mercredi qui sort ces
pièces a tourné à l avantage c'est que
ça empêche encore une fois les nord de
roquet et que la cie un rock qui aurait
un piège thématiques y aurait
maintenant fou proches cet échec qui
donne le fou il faut prendre le fou mais
ton avec le cavalier lecavalier
maintenant la tour on voit que la tour
peut prendre la dame voilà tout à fait
avec une position ici on donc après la
reprise par exemple du pion ou du fou il
ya deux des avantages et des
inconvénients dans les deux cas on voit
que les blancs windham contre un fou et
une tour est un pion c'est donc pas
forcément simple mais en tout cas on n'a
pas gagné la dame s'est pas vraiment
tolérable a priori cette position est
techniquement gagnante mais il faut
encore la transformer autre chose
stéphane dans cette version du blanc
crée une menace directe c'est que même
si c'est pas faux contre cet échec c'est
de cinq échecs loubet cinq échecs qui
gagnera la dame de la même façon voilà
donc les menaces de vladimir kramnik
vérité sport jo damage 5 dans cette
position donc non il n'empêche plus de
trois ou quatre il n'empêche que trois
ou quatre
effectivement et d'ailleurs c'était le
bon coup c'était bon coup peut-être le
dit mercredi qui a fait une légère
imprécision il a joué le coup h3 si ce
n'est pas très bon pas très fort c'est
vrai que joël lautier mahdi un coup
comme h3 on n'a jamais envie de jouer
contre kasparov
oui c'est vrai que c'est un coût qui a
priori perdu tant il fallait aller
directement de la vente dont le coût est
de 3 ou 4 avec un léger avantage pour
les 10 mercredi qu' à cause des raisons
conventionnés tout à l'heure ce pion à
six qui est faible foule essaie de
couper le khalife 6 aussi donc là il y
avait une petite vanne tactique à base
de quel g4 mais dans cette position bon
il ya des complications énorme qui
surgissent après fou des trois ans b5 et
chaque au roi on va vous passez les
détails mais pour les joueurs entraînés
et bien le push to b 5 échecs en tout
cas donnent des très bonnes possibilités
pour les blancs sacrifice de pièces
assez assez en finesse dont vladimir
kramnik à juhasz 3 mais la grosse
combinaison arriver un peu plus tard
c'est pour ça qu'on va pas trop
commenter l'ouverture stéphane tour des
huit tours de 8 demande pourquoi elle a
par ok cette fois maintenant kasparov et
leur rupture ok tu espères tu n'as pas
envie de rock est dans cette position il
a plutôt envie comme on le verra tout à
l'heure eh bien on verra tout à l'heure
justement tourner vite mettant donc la
tour sur la colonne des c'est un plan de
centralisation des pièces très
clairement
carrie kasparov ici mais ces pièces en
jeu il aurait pu rock et aussi mais il
n'a pas voulu faire qu'avec des cadres
de vladimir kramnik ça c'est un coup
surprise un coup surprise
à noter quand même que coups précédents
aussi kramis effet un kasparov aurait pu
prendre un f3 pour casser un peu la
structure des pions de l'oeil droit
alors dans cette position stéphane je
pense que prendre un f3 est une grosse
faute positionnelle on va expliquer
pourquoi ça a l'air bon pourtant puisque
ça va casser il faut prendre de la dame
il faut prendre de la dame bien entendu
il est en échange et il semblerait que
la les pions de l'ale roi sans casser
mais on a donné la paire de fou on a
donné la peur de fou mais plus grave que
ça donc on voit que le pion à six est
faible est attaqué par le fou les blancs
menace de jouer à 5 qui va bloquer ce
pion en a six on a la peur de fou on est
en finale
la structure des pions n'est pas encore
déterminé le centre est ouvert
donc ça donne des énormes avantages
positionnelle donc au blanc c'est à dire
le dit mercredi
ce qui explique qu'on ne veut pas fou
pour un f3 en règle générale c'est pas
très bon de prendre avec 3 sauf si ça
nous donne justement une attaque énorme
dans cette position après je crois tout
proche 3 c'est un coup d' attaque qui
allait changer d'âme tout de suite après
c'était une mauvaise idée tour des huit
cahiers des quatre cas les d4 a l'air de
perdre le pion à l'heure de perdre un
pion mais n'en faites sinon ça marche
pas parce qu'ils foutent des 5 à la fin
on va commenter ça tout de suite
fou prend des 4 c'est donc ça le coup
qui ferait perdre un pion on jouerait
d'un programme qu'elle manie prend et
puis on prend des 4 donc là on voit une
fois de plus j'espère de fou garde-fous
encore et surtout reprend des caps donc
ce serait la continuation logique pour
les noirs il y aurait encore ce fameux
fou b5 et châteauroux cheikh suivi de
ramassage de la tour avec un gain l'a
cette fois ci beaucoup plus simple que
avant puisque on a une qualité plus donc
c'est tout à fait standard comme bien
qu'elle ait des quatre dans cette
position-là des caries kasparov n'a pas
joué dame prend 1,2 et là on peut donner
une citation de chroniques dans cette
position garry kasparov n'a pas échangé
les dames parce qu'il s'est souvenu que
ses vieux démons de londres où il avait
perdu une position à peu près similaire
on peut dire que kramnik dans cette
partie a fait un choix psychologique en
janvier des quatre peut-être qu'il avait
tout anticipé il n'a pas joué aux quatre
avant il s'est dit je vais jouer qui
avaient des quatre parce que maintenant
kasparov et changera peut-être pas les
âmes et c'est effectivement garry
kasparov a joué d'amd 5
il est revenu menace en maths quand même
menaçant matin une menace qu'il faut
préciser menaçant mois tanger d'un
projet 2 le baiser de la mort toujours
la dame qui vient embrasser le roi est
ici vladimir kramnik revient bref 3 donc
ça a l'air d'être une proposition de
l'implicite mais derrick tait sport
flare refuse aux îles j'ouvre cette île
jour où il estime qu'il est mieux il
estime qu'il est mieux mais on peut
aussi se dire à l'opposé stéphane
l'admirent krasniqi a peut-être joué
cabine est roi mais n'aurait pas répéter
les coups après puisqu'il avait d'autres
options il faut déjouer par exemple le
trou avec ap je pense que la gary
kasparov a voulu profiter de son
avantage à la pendule puisqu'il était
déjà un petit peu mieux et il restait à
peu près 17 18 minutes contre une
dizaine à vladimir kramnik c'est un
énorme avantage autant puisque ça veut
dire que garry kasparov habitent c'est
complètement le début alors que le crâne
et qui réfléchit beaucoup ici voulait
l'exploiter direct et sports froid aux 7
c'est là que commence la combinaison une
très très belle combinaison de la
dynamique qui va en quelques coups
remettre le fou et la tour en jeu c'est
à dire que dans cette position il s'est
dit vladimir kramnik quelle pièce ne
joue pas et comment faire pour les faire
jouer
enfin il s'est pas dit ça parce qu'il
s'est déjà au fond de lui qu'il est quel
est le problème la position des blancs
mais il a trouvé une solution et ses
superbes sacrifice de pions donc
sacrifice d'options puisqu'on sait plus
ici si les blancs john passion on sait
pas quand ils vont se développer un coup
comme fou des deux c'est moche ouais
c'est moche et ça a pas l'air efficace
sa part le foot est roi surtout que sa
part le foot est roi c'est donc pas
efficace du tout un autre coup c'est dur
a proposé par exemple coup franc à six
et bien ça marche pas ça perd la tour d
un un coup comme un fou ces deux ça va
échanger des pièces mais c'est pas beau
on n'arrive pas à sortir nos pièces il
faut donc envoyé la combinaison 18 aux 4
garry kasparov se retrouve avec les
pièces de chroniques qui sortent
il est donc obligé de prendre ce option
stéphane je pense qu'on peut aller où il
faut prendre le pian et sinon c'est un
aveu de faiblesse
il faut relever le défi l'option étant
attaqué trois fois et défendre
uniquement deux fois il est en prise
cavaliers franck yeo quatre attaques
maintenant le pion à f2 le cavalier
l'attaquant également ça veut dire que
c'est une menace
il faut l'éviter je l'admiré indique
fait fou à trois tout ça ça a été
anticipée évidemment on voit là on voit
davantage de recettes aussi c'est qu'il
ya plus fous des cinq échecs
ouais je n'ai fouet trois maintenant
menace foot franck et radio 4 celui de
foot français cinq échecs
il faut éviter ça avec les noirs fou
prend fou en trois dames prend 1 3 il ya
eu donc un échange de fou le cavalier ou
quatre maintenant y d'attaqué ou pas là
pour 4 n'est pas vraiment une menace
d'ailleurs dams et 5 900 donc ils
invitent les charges des dames
ils se retrouvent avec effectivement il
va se retrouver avec m tourne plus qu'à
ce parent ça c'est un bon réflexe qui à
garry kasparov dans cette position quand
vous avez un pion de plus ou du matériel
en plus et bien échanger les dames c'est
en général une bonne solution pour
simplement gagner la partie dans un
style technique
on n'est pas obligé de jouer pour le
match quand on a ramassé déjà un ou deux
pions on a déjà gagné la partie
il faut savoir transformer dame c5
échange des amériques à plein plus c'est
le geste était mais kramnik ne permet
pas ça il joue le ku'damm un don qu'il
évite s'échangent des dames damien qui
est mieux dans vos deux puisque sa garde
un oeil sur le plan b 4 tout le temps
alors sur la case o2 s'était pas tout à
fait le cas maintenant
le cavalier e 4 se retrouvent réellement
attaqué cardiaque six tours à ses seins
d'un v6 est à quai ce convoi est bien
comparons la position avec celle qu'il y
avait quelques coups avance les fans
avant le coup et 4 c'était celle-là on
voit les pièces de chroniques qui sont
toutes toutes là à l'agonie à la maison
encore à la maison alors qu'après la
petite séquence de coûts force et qu'il
a trouvé bien on se retrouve dans cette
position
c'est plus du tout pareil on a donné un
pion mais on a tout sorti on a tous
sortis mais en ce1 se dit que les noirs
et leur manque le plus beaucoup de coups
pour sortir leur dernière pièce qu'est
la tourache 8 et qu'il ya quand même un
qui en plus il ya quand même un peu plus
c'est vrai dans cette position vladimir
kramnik a vu plus loin évidemment il a
vu que ces pièces avaient une activité
énorme avec le cahier qui vient sur la
caisse de 5 et à la casse et si ce qui
est très faible
ça ça va jouer et on va voir maintenant
ça va être du grand style cavaliers ou 5
tout de suite tour des quatre temps des
quatre pour activer la tourache 8
c'est la faute décisive difficile
difficile à dire quand même difficile à
dire c'était pas facile à comprendre
mais dans cette position le coutour
d'habitants des quatre paires de manière
pratiquement forcé
passionnant faut le voir il faut le voir
et d'ailleurs on va voir mon lacet on
peut pas vraiment poser cette question
aux internautes qui nous regardent
stéphane parce que c'est quand même très
très compliqué oui dans cette position
il y avait des bons coups je pense que
il fallait jouer quelque chose comme
cavani des cinq un coude qui renforce la
position qu'ils qui rend tout ça solide
et compacte tour des quatre la faute
dans cette position il y avait caillassé
4 qui est intéressant mais vladimir
kramnik a vu beaucoup plus jolie
beaucoup plus beau foot champions à 6 un
coup qu'on peut qualifier
d'extraterrestres extraterrestres se
demande ce que va faire le fou sur las
casas ici les emprises on va attendre
des quatre est protégé par la dame
salaires nos perdre une pièce salaire de
perdre une classe alors première
remarque stéphane après fou prend fois
ci est bien ici ça gagne tout de suite à
cause de la fourche à ton c6 cavalli c6
échec échec au roi et on prend la tour
descartes au coup d'après voilà donc
déjà se fout et pas prenable tout de
suite donc bien entendu il ya tour
contours d un intermédiaire voilà c'est
à dire que là on met une tour ici qui
est très forte
donc c'est un échange de tours les
blancs sont obligés d'aller reprendre la
tour ils reprennent avec la tour alors
qu'ils avaient repris avec la dame ça
faisait après tour des huit une partie à
peu près égales pour prendre et 1
laissant le faux emprise puisque
maintenant il ya plus cette combinaison
avec kelis et 6 échec puisque déjà le
cas l'isf serait pas défendu en plus y'a
plus rien on décape n'y a plus rien ne
marche
donc on se demande ce qui se passe sur
fou prend à 6 c'est ce que fait kasparov
c'est ce que fait kasparov bien entendu
et la balle assez c'est tout à fait
fantastique qui suit il a une pièce de
moins me l'a dit mercredi qu'une pièce
net de - on voit il a plus qu'un
cavalier 6 en mai pyongyang de l'adamo
sinon prendre de la dame ainsi prendre
la dame s'est plutôt heureux
non c'est je crois qu'il ya maintenant
quelques coups s'il prend de la dame s'y
prend la dernière dame prend b 4 échecs
ça va aller très très vite d'un prend b4
échec au roi là il y a donc le coup
droit huit forcé et maintenant on monte
la tour de d1 sur la caisse 10,6 et là
ça commence à chauffer ça commence à
chauffer méchamment parce que la dame
est attaqué cette dame en bécade peut
prendre le fou 17 peut venir faire échec
sur la caisse b5 suivi d'un math rapide
dans cette position je crois qu'on peut
dire que la position de garry kasparov
et désespéré ça paraît beaucoup plus
logique de prendre à 6 avec le fou
d'autant plus que dans cette position
donc on donne pas le plan b 4 avec échec
il n'y a pas d'échec possible pour les
blancs ou alors en tout cas salaire de
peur du matériel donc qu'est-ce qui se
passe et vous qu'est ce qui se passe
mais eh bien il se passe que vladimir
kramnik joue dame propre tombe et quatre
échecs mettant la dame reprises donnant
la dame
garry kasparov est obligé de prendre
cavaliers ces six échecs fourchette
récupère la dame puisque ces attaques
en même temps le roi et la dame est à
noter que roy 8 serait sanctionné par un
match immédiat 3,8
on n'irait pas se laisser distraire par
la dame on jouerait tour des huit échecs
et mat puisque le roi noir n'a plus de
cases lecavalier contrôlant et la caisse
d'éviter la case là et la tour les deux
dernières pièces mais de maths
voilà exactement un match très plein
stress a obligé le deun le prochain coup
kasparov qui a obligé de jouer roi et
suite à la fuite le geste technique de
vladimir kramnik qui ne prend pas la
dame immédiatement mais qui colle
d'abord un échec intermédiaire tour des
mythes et chats tour des huit échecs qui
ramène le cavalier sur la case 8 où il
sera moins actif que ie8 force et en
plus la tour de trafiquants des 8 est
très très forte
cavalier prend dam des quatre attaquants
le fou continuant à attaquer le foot
donc on voit que la séquence efforcé
depuis faut prendre ses distances des
femmes c'est tout et forcés dans cette
position c'est la première fois que
garry kasparov à un choix il peut jouer
soit fougue et cette soif ou c4 soit x 2
soit le courroye hausse est beaucoup de
possibilités pour garry kasparov
mais elles sont toutes mauvaises et il
n'a pas l'air en fait le problème c'est
que on va voir c'est que ce fou à 6
finalement va se retrouver piégé le fois
ci s'est piégé dans la vente de la
partie mais le problème pour généraliser
un peu plus c'est qu'il ya un pion à 4
qui est très fort qui avance très vite
c'est une vraie flèche
on peut aller à dame et l'autre problème
énorme ses sept tours en débit qui est
complètement monstrueuse puisque
derrière il ya la tourache vite le roi
et le cavalier donc à elle seule elle
immobilise trois pièces noires
effectivement on peut dire que ici y'a
de la tacc ou en tout cas il ya une
activité de pièces énorme
malgré le fait qu'il reste presque plus
de matériel aux glandes il n'y a plus
que deux pièces mais elles sont sûres
dynamique faux de faux 2 le choix de
garry kasparov
on peut commenter d'autres coûts je ne
sais pas par exemple le couffo bessette
wef ou 17
mais qu'est-ce qui se passerait si
refonder s'est trouvé cette nuit on
pousse ses pions à direct on n'a pas le
temps pas de temps à perdre
supposons le coup droit cette tourbe et
vite
et maintenant je sais pas trop ce qui
peut se passer
le foot revient sur la case de 4 par
exemple ou aux 4 et lâche trop rares
j'aurais f3 f3 et après 1,6 et ensuite
on pousse le pion puisqu'on voit que
lecavalier ans et 7 est complètement
bloquée puisque la tourache 8 avec la et
clouer un ceux qui veulent y explorer de
la tourache 8 étant prises derrière
donc là on peut plus empêcher le pion à
d'avancé donc ça c'est une première
variante qui montre bien ce qui se passe
le coup choisi par garry kasparov ses x
2 et là on va voir ses superbes vladimir
kramnik ne pousse pas son pion à ne fait
rien il joue simplement le coup f2 f3
avec une idée cacher des diaboliques
l'idée complètement diabolique dans
cette position c'est clair l'idée c'est
en fait d'un kasparov qu'est-ce que tu
joues qu'est ce qui vous fait un plus
question jouer en plus j'ai un rêve des
cases à temps fou exactement je rêve des
cas ça t'en fous on voit que le fou ne
peut plus partir par là puisqu'il est
bloqué par le pion ça c'est plus une
c'est plus une option garry kasparov il
y pas facile je sors ma tour de loin
ouais je vais faire une manoeuvre de
sortie très longue un peu artisanal mais
en tout cas j'ai quand même une pièce de
plus si j'arrive à sortir ma tour eh
bien je vais gagner la partie
maintenant b2 b3 superbe contrôle encore
une thèse du fou alors là on voit
maintenant on va compter les cases
restantes pour le fou donc il ya celle
là qui est contrôlé par le cavalier par
la tour le pion contrôler le plan
contrôle le cavalier contrôler la tour
contrôle le roi contrôle et là on voit
que le pion la bloquer donc le fou n'a
plus de cases donc maintenant garry
kasparov ne peut plus rien faire ils
jouent tour à 6,3 f2 attaque le fou qui
n'a plus de gaz qui n'a plus de cases
qui est perdu pour g6 garry kasparov
sort péniblement sa tour
roy prend fou pour plonger de bilan
matériel
c'est toujours égalité matérielle
maintenant stéphane
rami qui a récupéré sa pièce mais
kasparov a pris un pion au passage
simplement il ya une différence
d'activité des pièces qui est énorme
différence d'activité et surtout actions
passées à qui est très rapide
si on passait à extrêmement rapide le
roi de la dîmière kramnik qui est au
centre en d3 comparé au roi de kasparov
qui est en fuite dont qui est encore
très loin
on rappelle un grand principe en finale
stéphane en finale et bien il faut
mettre le roi au centre le roi est une
pièce forte ou et le roi est une pièce
qu'il faut activer autant il ya au début
il faut les mettre à l'abri quand tu es
encore les dames autant à la fin ils
deviennent pièce avec une grosse
activité puisqu'ils contrôlent beaucoup
de cases garry kasparov continue à se
battre tours g3 le clown chronique
avance en a cinq
là ils se laissent plus distraire par
des pions maintenant vladimir kramnik
tout reprend avec trois échecs trois c4
on voit que le roi vient soutenir le
pion à et maintenant il ya plus de
défense contre l'avancée de ses pions
stéphane garry kasparov décide
d'abandonner superbe impressionnant
impressionnant ce fou prend assise qui
sortent de nulle part et surtout en
partie rapide failli le voir c'est clair
c'est clair non très très très belle
vraiment superbe victoire de vladimir
kramnik il faut dire que maintenant il a
vraiment posé à kasparov un complexe de
sports on a l'impression qu'il sait plus
jouer contre wladimir carnet
oui c'est plus jouer
enfin disons qu il quand même bloqué à
noter quand même que avec les blancs
kasparov s'est heurté une nouvelle fois
la défense berlinoise et qu' une
nouvelle fois kramnik a tenu avec ce un
problème
rami qui a tenu très très facilement
dans cette défense berlinoise donc on
rappelle tournoi anniversaire de victor
cornouaille pour ses soixante dix ans
victoire de vladimir kramnik kibale
garry kasparov kornoi s'en porte pas
trop mal il s'est qualifié pour les
quarts de finale il a été éliminé contre
kasparov
c'est parce qu'il est aussi étaient
qualifiés en quarts de finale il a été
éliminé par short en tout cas au final
c'est vladimir kramnik qui bat kasparov
c'est le souvenir qu'on gardera de ce
tournoi on gardera également souvenir
que victor croque notes joue très très
bien
on est toujours très bien il s'est fait
éliminé que par le king kasparov alors
changement de sujet mémorial câble en
gamme et moins capable en cas je crois
qu'on va voir une partie modèle oui une
partie modèle puisqu'elle se joue elle
se joue à très peu de coups entre miles
et igor nataf mind control gorna table
donc on va rester sur l'échiquier pour
regarder cette deuxième partie du
programme diagonale effectivement dès
que ça sera prêt le voilà donc on va
passer assez rapidement sur l'ouverture
parce qu'on a très vite envie d'aller à
la combinaison stéphane une combinaison
qui est tout à fait excellentes
ouais donc d4 c'est tony maïs qui est en
anglais un petit peu
farfelu ouais ouais il peut parler de ça
ouais ouais phare celui complètement
farfelu contre les guerres nataf si
opening spécialistes le spécialiste des
ouvertures
il travaille comme un fou tout le temps
et il connaît sur le bout des doigts
ces ouvertures donc là il a déjoué est
indienne mais miles lui a dit stop
mais lui a dit stop hop je te je fais un
mur contre temps fou g7 exactement fou
g7
on voit que donc ça c'est un chantier
tôt le fou s'est mis sur la grande
diagonale mais tony miles lui il lui a
mis des pions pour le contrer ou g5 il
sort ses pièces petit rock qu'avaient
les bd 2 des 6 e 4 tout ça c'est très
classique c5 une attaque
normal il faut absolument miner le
centre ça c'est un réflexe dans toutes
les ouvertures aux échecs
dès 5h 6h à cluj et 5 x 4 au 6 toujours
la tête du centre comprend aussi cela
c'est un coin typique qui est jouée par
tony miles normalement on dit qu'il faut
pas prendre aussi ce parce qu'après vous
prend et bien les noirs ont énormément
d'activité ce qui a l'air vrai dans
cette position mais miles a vu plus loin
fous ces quatre ils essaient dé changer
les pièces des cinq joué par igor nataf
qui on prend des 5 fu prend petit rock
petit rock um mes droits à l'abri et là
une différence fondamentale entre les
deux positions stéphane c'est que les
blancs ont complètement anéanti la force
du fou g7 alors qu'en revanche les noirs
doivent supporter ce fou h4 qui cloue le
cavaliere cissé qui est donc une pièce
plus forte que le foot à savoir qui est
embêtant c'est toujours embêtant ce club
il faut donc dire que comparativement
ici les blancs est un avantage puisque
leur [ __ ] 4 noir est bien plus fort
que le foot gaz ward et noir alors que
les deux autres pourront s'échanger
qu'elle et ses six dames ces deux
cavaliers à 5 ça c'est une faute
il faut pas exporter votre cavaliers à
la bande très clairement igor nataf
aurait pu trouver mieux dans cette
position s'était pas le bon coup fou
prend des cinq d'un prend des 5
ici il ya un léger avantage pour les
blancs mais tony mansfeld transformée en
deux coups tours a des seins
damages cinq fautes décisives déjà
paraît curieux ouais déjà faute décisive
ouais enfin pas tout à fait décisif mais
ici à partir de là on peut dire que les
noirs vont perdre un pion donc on va
vous laisser chercher un petit peu
peut-être 3 4 secondes
oui dans cette position les blancs ont
une combinaison absolument surprenante
ouest surprenantes pas tout à fait mais
bon alors attention faut pas se tromper
ce n'est pas un problème cinq étoiles de
libé c'est plus dur mais c'est plus dur
c'est très très dur même damas quatre
attaques lecavalier attaque le cavalier
qui est sûre la casa cinq cavaliers
cécilia b6 qui est possible aussi mais
qui perd pour les mêmes raisons et c6 le
choix des grands nataf et maintenant un
coup qu'on peut qualifier de difficile à
trouver dans la mesure où on a du mal à
y penser
ouais il faut donner un fou fou prend
cavaliers font cavalier fils fou prend
fou il à la pointe cavaliers aux quatre
cavaliers ou quatre attaques le fou
qu'est sur la case f6 bon jette un oeil
sur eux tuant ses 5000 est défendue par
la dame pour l'instant il ya plusieurs
défense possible pour les noirs et
plusieurs réponses après le couffo s'est
troué par igor et bien c'est la cagade
et brice qui lie à ici un enfermement
complètement inattendu de la dame d'igor
nataf
qu'avais-je des trois abandons abandon
cc abrupte c'est abrupte il faut
expliquer pourquoi alors et toutes les
cases sont contrôlés on voit la dame qui
est attaqué par le cavalier donc cette
case là est contrôlé par le cavalier
cette case là contrôlé par le cavalier
cette case là par le cavalier et cette
case là par les jours donc pour
l'instant de ce côté là foot la dame et
ramassés ici
eh bien il ya la dame blanche ici même
explication est ici eh bien il ya le
plan blanc donc on voit la dame noire ne
peut plus s'échapper et où elle a été
prise au piège prise au piège donc
stéphane qui mentionnait tout à l'heure
un 19 coups qu'il y avait une défense
possible qui était donc de jouer le coup
bessette des cinq une contre attaque
on est tous ça c'est un réflexe qu'il
faut avoir c'est vraiment un mec du
désespoir oui mais après dame fonction
des cinq et bien effectivement on a
libéré une place pour la dame mais on
tient à mon père le cavaly vers le
calice et 6 donc c'est terminé et donc
après kg 3 et bien igor nataf a capitulé
pas d'autres pas d'autre solution
malheureusement terrible complètement
terrible c'est vraiment beau
versant on peut regarder dans cette
position revoir les images au ralenti
qu'est-ce qui a fait que tony maïs à
trouver lorsqu'il aurait pas me trouver
une solution après cavaliers aux 4 quand
même alors après damas quatre l'idée du
ku'damm à 4 stéphane c'est de contrôler
la 4g 4 oui c'est ça c'est assez marrant
c'est à dire qu'on n'attaque pas on ne
fait pas que d'attaquer le cavalier à 5
on va aussi contre la thèse des quatre
pour l'enfermement futur donc en fait
comme anthony maïs a réfléchi je pense
qu'il s'est dit voilà je peux je fous
pour un f6 fou prend cavaliers 4 il
s'est dit ça dans cette position là je
peux les prendre prise qu'à venir 4 kg 3
mais la dame de igor aura la 4g 4
comment faire pour lui enlever cette
case up j'ai trouvé je fais damas quatre
essais s'il sait maintenant j'en vois le
truc fou prend faut prendre
cavani cas voilà ici et ce qui n'a pas
une solution à ce qu'on peut pas jouer
par exemple damev cinq dames et 5 tout à
fait c'est un coup jouable mais il ya je
crois tour des cinq petites anicroches
tactique ton des cinq puisque si la dame
vient prendre la tour des 5 et bien il y
accueille l'épreuve 6 fourchette way qui
va gagner la dame
donc après le tour des cinq il faut tout
à coup comme dame aux 6 ou d'un f4
d'amchit soins ou de 9,4 dames aussi de
nos 6 par exemple est là et bien il y
aurait tout simplement tour des six qui
ramassent le foufou qui ramassent le fou
et sur dame f4 et sur de 9,4 donc
nouvelles possibilités
après tour des cinq dames f4 il y aurait
moins ya plusieurs plusieurs choix il ya
tour 17 qui est très fort qui rentre
complètement les pièces on va prétendre
17 ya suis vraiment défend stéphane on
va ramasser pions bessette on peut
toujours prendre f6 quand on en a envie
lequel c6 est faible donc ici
effectivement on peut dire que les noirs
ont limité la casse
oui mais vous quand même perdre option
bessette et après ça devient
techniquement perdre contre un en tout
cas contre un grand maître comme tony
bates qui dans ce genre de position peut
le dire assure pas mal bien vu mais bon
c'est vrai que là c'est quand même une
cagade quoi disons que s'il l'avait vue
il aurait joué dans 900 bien entendu
bien entendu igor s'est laissé
surprendre par kg 3 il n'a pas
soupçonner que saddam puissent être
enfermées
effectivement c'est le problème donc fin
des parties commentées
stéphane je crois que travailler encore
une commune de man troisième et on a un
reporter spécial donc pour la chasse
people qui est à cannes que nous allons
joindre en direct noël et notre célèbre
collaborateurs maintenant jean luc sudan
de chabannes ans qui au festival du film
à cannes festival du film
très intéressant donc voyais alors
qu'est ce qu'il fait là bas et bien
c'est simple jean-luc chavanon
s'intéresse à la vie des stars
on peut dire que c'est le stéphane bern
des échecs il a donc été suivre tout ce
qui se passait à cannes
donc dès qu'il sera en ligne et bien
nous allons lui parler on va donc là il
mène son enquête pour l'instant on
rappelle quand même stéphane donc la
pourchasse people que jean-luc chavanon
vient d'être grand maître wii vient d'un
grand maître il a eu sa troisième norme
au tournoi enfin nationale je crois
c'est nationale ain touta personnage
emploi transport à qui on va rappeler
d'ailleurs que c'est monaco qui est
champion voilà au salon pourront lire à
dire un petit mot là dessus à la fin sur
monaco champion de france donc je ne
sais pas non grand maître d'échecs qu'il
a il vient de fêter son titre hier à
cannes il est donc comme un fou et nous
l'avons tout de suite en ligne à l'eau
et non
[Musique]
j'ai ce people avec jean-luc chavanon
propre direct de cannes
jean-luc bonjour et loi alors là nous
avons une incrustation de jean-luc alors
tu es tu es à cannes et qu'est ce qui se
passe est ce qu'il ya des stars du jeu
d'échecs qui sont sur la croisette
et oui comme d'habitude il y ait des
stars partout partout en france est
actuellement donc il y a une il ya notre
numéro un franco kazakh l'abus slap
quatre chefs qui il était à cannes
figure fille est donc là que les filles
l'actualité très chargée
alors qu'est ce qu'il a fait vladislav à
cannes pourquoi il est là bas et donc 27
l'efs qui est la leur a même mis rateur
un inconditionnel de sophie marceau a
fait la montée des marches donc pour la
cérémonie d'ouverture
et il est donc allé voir le film
australien moulin rouge donc un film
australien produit par les américains et
sur une histoire française donc pour en
jouer en cash back et russes qui joue en
france
c'était parfait voilà donc un grand
moment mais quand jean-luc c'est très
clair donc tu as peut-être titre là à
cannes puisque tu viens d'être en maître
au cas d'échec de cannes ça s'est bien
passé
évidemment et donc je viens de fêter mon
titre au club de cas d'échec on as était
également notre première place ex-aequo
aux championnats de france par équipes
et donc le champagne coule à flots sur
la côte d'azur donc là dessus en direct
de la croisette sur la plage orange est
ce que ce sera la fête a été folle il ya
eu les meilleures amies donc
meurt tout leur talent l'entraîneur de
vlad et mon président du club c'était
c'était vraiment un grand moment
d'accord donc chase people en ce moment
il se passe rien de particulier rien à
dire sur le rang fasciné laurent
frayssinet oui donc leur entrée phinney
qui depuis son grand retour à la maison
un come-back phare marseille et il est
rentré voir ses parents pour se reposer
avant le championnat d'europe qui aura
lieu donc bientôt en macédoine d'accord
et bien jean-luc on va te remercier pour
ces nouvelles people des stars du jeu
d'échecs et puis on se donne rendez vous
dès que tu es rentré de cannes tout
simplement voilà à bientôt
merci voilà jean luc je n'ai que
schumann en pleine forme d'un direct de
cannes je crois qu'il est allé voir un
film japonais nous a dit oui il est très
très friands de la culture
cinématographique japonaise donc jean
luc chabanon en direct de cannes on
rappelle que ça a quand même été sa
nation serait enfin son fief pendant
deux années puisqu'il a été entraîneur
du club de cannes ça fait trois ou
quatre ans qu'il joue pour le club et
s'étaient installés là-bas dans un
appartement avec quand même vue sur la
mer très très bel appartement de jeunes
chefs dans 24 il a quitté puisque
maintenant il est venu habiter sur paris
jean-luc oui voilà donc fin de la
rubrique chess people on va terminer
avec l'annoncé des tournois peut-être
puisqu'il ya pas mal d'éléments qu'on a
ratée avec le sénat stéphane oui
donc il ya beaucoup de choses qui est
beaucoup de news notamment la femme de
joël lautier almira skripchenko
graphique qui devenu champion d'europe
féminine championne d'europe donc
mira qui a battu en match de départage
alyssa gal yam au vallon de choc
donc on voit beaucoup de femmes de
joueurs dans le championnat d'europe
alyssa galliano va donc a été la fin du
monde choc et elle a gagné
reporter cette compétition c'est quand
même pas mal ouais c'est pas mal je
crois que les achats féminin le niveau
monte
oui c'est elle n'est pas française je
crois les moldaves jour moldave
enfin il joue pour l'équipe de mon avis
oui mais là la nationalité française
doit être double nationalité mais elles
jouent pas le championnat de france
féminin
non non non elle ne joue pas je pense
qu'elle a pas spécialement envie de le
jouer dans la mesure où elles seraient
énormes favorite
il ya pas vraiment de match et là plus
de 2500 points elo alors que la
meilleure française n'a que deux mille
trois cents en tout cas il ya marie ce
bagues dont les échecs le n 1 français
qui peut commencer à lui poser des
problèmes puisqu'elle est jeune et
complètement imprévisible on est tout à
fait fidèles à elles progressé très vite
en tout cas nous félicitons almira pour
sa victoire aux championnats d'europe
elle jouera très prochainement le
championnat du monde féminin qui aura
lieu bientôt aux championnats du monde
fis des féminins fiscale sur le
championnat d'europe était qualificative
donc même système pour les pour les
hommes le championnat le fameux choc
dont parlait jean luc où il y aura
quarante six places qualificatives 46
places ça a l'air énorme mais en fait
c'est très très dur puisque stéphane ils
seront tous là ils seront tous là et on
sait très bien enfin de toute façon
c'est les européens qui domine la scène
mondiale des échecs
alors qu'on voit jamais que chabanon en
fond d'écran ce qui est ce qui est
toujours très très plaisant très très
plaisant donc c'est les européens qui
domine la scène mondiale de jeux
d'échecs dont 46 places qualificatives
c'est pas mal puisque bon c'est quand
même il ya 100 joueurs qualifiés en tout
oui il y en a pas mal qui sont qualifiés
les lots directement voilà donc bon je
pense que c'est quand même bon bon ratio
ça a dû être calculé en fonction du
classement elo tout simplement début du
tournoi de sarajevo pour la semaine
prochaine mais ça donc on en parlera à
la semaine prochaine à noter que le
tournoi est beaucoup moins fort que
l'année passée oui est passé c'était un
top quand il y avait il ya vait kasparov
krainik n'y avait pas kramnik avec la
star of shirov adams des dents comme
nombreuses et match aller commander
c'était un très fort tournoi là il n'y
aura pas kasparov figure en revanche
topalov kiril georgiev qui sont les
laits meilleur joueur bulgare dont il y
aura évidemment des très fort joueur
mais en tout cas c'est pas de ce niveau
là monaco champion de france vous allez
toujours curieux mais monaco est
français il faut quand même rappeler
championnat de france par équipes
situation très tendue on rappelle que
clichy dominé le championnat avec son
équipe très très forte son équipe massue
dans les premiers échiquiers gris tchouk
vente velits joël lautier et yevgeny bas
relief donc une très très belle équipe
oui en plus au niveau des français c'est
pas mal non plus puisqu'ils après il ya
pis elana daf et olivier rhône et neuf
grands maîtres dans l'équipe enfin 8
plus marie saubade les sugar et céline
la meilleure féminine française
clairement il y avait l'équipe de monaco
avec michael adams qui marche très bien
mais les lois rôle en jeu donc et loire
où l'enjeu au passage joyon qui a bien
joué le dernier week-end qu'a bien joué
les derniers week-ends et notamment la
partie contre clichy parti contre
clichés on va donc avant d'aborder ce
match là il y avait donc clichy qui
avait un point d'avancé sur cannes et
monaco mais clichy devait jouer les deux
les deux clubs
clichy joue contre cannes et perd le
match donc trois clubs se retrouve
ex-aequo cannes monaco clichy tous
ex-aequo monaco joue contre eux clichy
donc avantage pour cannes monaco bas
clichy effectivement match gagnait 2 1
c'est des matches qui sont très chaud
dans la mesure où la moyenne est l'eau
est très proche c'est 2532 moyenne sur 9
échiquier c'est énorme
donc c'est ça se joue à très peu de
choses il ya très peu de victoires très
peu de défaites tout le monde joue un
très très solide on veut pas perdre dans
ces matches là
donc victoire 2 à 1 pour monaco c'est
igor shitov qui a perdu contre lui rené
alors que justement j'ai battu à pisser
la haie
il ya eu encore une victoire mais je ne
sais plus qui c'était c'est marc siano
je pense la féminine nord marcelo qui a
battu un anglais qui a battu ebden ou
kosten donc au stand enfin je sais plus
peu importe donc monaco champion de
france par équipes 2e cannes 3e clichy
donc un très beau podium final trois
très belles équipes l'équipe de cannes
avec jean-luc chavanon notamment
puisqu'on va citer les collaborateurs
des annales qu'il joue le champion de
france par équipes où jean-luc chavanon
joué à cannes
il a gagné avec y'avait morte à ce
qu'est ce qu'elle est f
vladislav tkachiev une équipe jeune
sympa et branchée qui étaient là bas
dernière activité en ce moment le
tournoi de salou en espagne
alors ça c'est un tournoi qui est
organisée par le couple hicham hamdouchi
et arthur cogan couple au niveau
organisationnel et vise à organiser par
un homme de cheez whiz organisé par des
joueurs d'échecs qui sont allés
s'installer à sa douville très
sympathique proche de barcelone et qui
organise régulièrement des tournois de
grand maître
donc c'est détonnant qui sont ouverts à
tous cd tournoi fermé mais ouvert donc
c'est un concept spécial c'est à dire
que l'on peut se faire inviter à salou
il faut se renseigner
contactés ni shameem douchy donc il ya
les informations sur les sur des sites
internet en ce moment est donc là il ya
une grosse présence française puisqu'il
ya santoro mans didier colas davout de
pira également robert fontaine qui
marche très très bien puisqu'il va
peut-être réaliser une lambo m bravo
voilà tournoi de celle où donc
stéphane je crois qu'on a
je crois qu'on l'a mentionné je crois
qu'on a fait le tour et qu'on arrive à
la fin de l'émission on va rappeler la
victoire laurent frayssinet au sénat
alors en fait au sénat et on se donne
rendez-vous à la semaine prochaine pour
une nouvelle édition diagonale
[Musique]
et
vous
[Musique]
oui
bon
[Musique]